In this expert interview,
we'll be speaking with doctor
Brian Commute son who's
an associate professor of
psychology at Stanford University and
the director of the symbiotic project on
affect of neuroscience. And he is one
of the leading figures in this area.
We'll speak with us about the field
of neuroeconomics and emotion.
So doctor Knutson,
um,
received his bachelor degree in psychology
and comparative religion from Trinity
University and his Phd from Stanford
University after which he did postdoctoral
research and affect of neuroscience
at the medical school and the National
Institute of Health.
His laboratory uses multiple
methods including psychometrics,
psychophysiology brain
imaging and pharmacology to
investigate neuro mechanisms
that underlie emotional experience.
And he also explores implications of
this work for clinical disorders have an
effect and addiction as well as
for economic decision making.
Their discovery that neural activity
correlates with expected value and can be
used to predict choice,
including financial risk taking and
product purchases has helped seed new and
exciting interdisciplinary
fields including neuro economics,
neuro finance and neuromarketing.
Dr [inaudible] has received young
investigator awards from the American
Psychiatric Association,
the National Alliance for research
on schizophrenia and depression.
And the Academy of
Behavioral Medicine Research.
He's also a fellow of the American
Psychological Society and Academy of
Behavioral Medicine Research.
His research is funded by grants
from several organizations,
including the National Institutes of
Health and National Science Foundation.
He's been invited to speak about his
research and psychology, psychiatry,
neuroscience, economics, finance and
marketing departments around the world.
And his laboratories.
Research is regularly featured in top
journals and popular media outlets.
So I now turn to our very special
experts and emotion interview with Doctor
Brian Knutson. So welcome, Brian.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me.
So I know we're all curious to know a bit
about what got you first interested in
emotion.
Um,
I know that you came to this in a
path that isn't typical of everyone,
and I'd love to hear your story,
right? So this sort of dates me, but
when I was a psychology graduate student,
uh, people talked about
emotion and the brain somewhat,
but they never talked about
the two together. So, um,
I studied emotion at that time,
facial expression of emotion.
And I went to work with a guy named Paul
Ekman who studies facial expression of
emotion and I was a postdoc in his lab
and he noticed that I was spending a lot
of time taking classes in the
medical school and he said to me, uh,
you can continue doing this.
You're doing your work, it's fine,
but you really want to do this,
go this route.
Then you need to work with somebody who
thinks about the brain and thinks about
emotion. Uh, and there are only three
people in the world who do that right now.
Uh, one was Richie Davidson and that was
Joe to do in other was Jaak Panksepp.
So I decided to take the risk
and go work with Jaak in.
And he was very interesting at that time
because he was claiming that animals
had emotion and you can
model it and in rats,
all these very radical things at the time.
So I did,
I went and worked with Yak and I really
got my hands dirty working with the
brain and neuro pharmacology.
And based on that,
that sort of sent me off on this weird
trajectory of affect of neuroscience.
I ended up at at uh,
uh,
the National Institute of
Health for another post doc.
And there I got exposure to brain
imaging. Uh, my boss basically said,
I have this time, do you want
to do something with it? And uh,
that then got me into brain imaging.
So I've always been interested in emotion,
but the neuroscience part came later.
We're married.
Cool. So I'd love to ask you a bit more
about your current research now. Um,
so I mean we can all relate to some
extent to the way that emotion shift,
the way we spend money or how our economic
situations influence how we feel in
the moment.
And your work is really cool here
because it looks at this sort of neuro
economics of emotion.
So this bridge is fields of psychology,
neuroscience and economics.
And it's this very timely and
exciting field to so many people.
And at the same time it's this rapidly
developing and, and new field as well.
And so I just wondered if you could share
with us some of the kind of scientific
puzzles that are gripping people in
studying these kinds of questions.
Absolutely. I mean, it's a
very exciting time. Yeah. Uh,
this technology for looking into the
brain, not only at the cortical level,
but deep in the subcortical level,
uh,
at a second to second temporal resolution
has really only been with us for the
past decade or so. So, uh, as
we're discovering new things,
we're also innovating new methods.
And that doesn't just apply to the
fancy magnets or the head coils,
but also to how you designed the study,
how you analyze your data.
Timing is really important.
And in fact,
one thing that we've been focusing on
is can you not only see arousal in the
brain,
but can you see valence,
which seems very basic from an
emotional perspective, but really it's,
it's a question that's at the root of
all studies of athletic and emotion.
And the reason we're so focused on
payments, meaning good versus bad,
is because we think that not only will
it allow us to see how people were
reacting to things,
but also what they're about to do.
And so we've specifically
focused on two emotional states,
which is rather limited,
really to be honest. Um,
two emotional states that we think
are evoked when people anticipate, uh,
uncertain, good events are
uncertain, bad events. Uh,
we call them positive
arousal and negative arousal,
and they fit right into this aspect
of framework. I'm thinking about, uh,
people's experience. So positive arousal
involves emotions like excitement,
energy, even pride. Uh,
negative arousal involves emotions
like anxiety, irritability, um,
and so,
uh,
these kinds of emotions are especially
important to us because we think that
they occur not only in response to
something that just happens and outcome,
but also in anticipation of
things that have not yet happened.
So they're truly psychological and we
also think that they drive behavior.
So they will push you towards
approach or avoidance respectively.
So they will in essence,
allow us to predict whether somebody
will approach or avoid a situation. Okay.
How fascinating.
So what do you think that are some of the
major challenges researchers are going
to face in this field of
neuroeconomics of emotion?
So one of the challenges,
a lot of them are sort of
the same challenges that
most emotion researchers face
when there's an additional layer.
So the same challenges that emotional
researchers face is that they want to
measure something that often is
assessed with self report, uh,
and correlate it with either, you know,
behavior or skin conductance, you know,
physiology or something like
that. And those correlations
can be pretty loose. Uh,
so, you know, people aren't always
aware of, I think what they're feeling,
but sometimes they can act in an emotional
way and not be aware of it or come up
with an explanation that
really isn't relevant to the
w why they behave that way.
In fact, we can set up
situations like that in the lab.
So one of the problems is that things
don't always hang together very well.
Another problem,
uh,
which is unique to our situation
is the problem of timing. Uh,
everything that we do,
uh,
we have to make predictions not only about
what will happen where, but also when,
especially when it comes
to anticipating things.
And so we have to think very carefully
about the timing of events that happens
in our, in our, in our both in
our experiments and our analysis.
And we have to be precise about that.
And that's something that in psychology,
you know,
some people have thought about,
but really we've lacked the technology
to sort of really link up physiological
measures online with emotional
tendencies and emotional self reports.
And what I mean by that is that you would
want to have sort of a self report of
good versus bad,
sort of on an ongoing scale.
But the very act of doing that kind of
a rating may interfere with the emotion.
And so there are a lot of technical issues
that we need to resolve to get things
on the same time scale so we can really
test our hypotheses about how affect
matches up with brain activity.
Well,
it's interesting you're talking about
timing and kind of the Tempur or focus of
the studies that we do because one of
the many amazing things you've done,
your research,
but one of them has really been to
parse apart the anticipation from the
consumption of rewards.
And so I know this is something that
is relevant to just a host of different
fields, not only in you know,
aspect of science, but in
clinical science, you know,
thinking about economic decision making.
And I wonder if you could just tell us
a little bit about what this distinction
is between wanting something
and liking something.
Right. So, um, I joke with
people that a lot of my,
you're imaging experiments that are really
built around rat experiments and it's
really true like going in and studying
rats and they're basic motivational
states really informs even our,
uh,
studies of how people decide whether to
invest or not or whether they want to
buy an item or not. Obviously ratchet
aren't doing this, but they're deciding,
I want to get that food. I want
to look away that Predator. Uh,
and we think that those motivational
surrogates are not only conserve but are
used by all of us in our day
to day decisions. Um, so, uh,
I want to make sure I get your, uh,
the answer your question, right.
Locations of this, what is the
difference between wanting and liking?
So once thanks in rats,
it's very interesting.
He's by Kent Berridge at the University
of Michigan is he's been able to
neurochemically and to some extent
in euro anatomically dissociate, um,
wanting,
what do you call is wanting from liking a,
and then he does these clever experiments
where he has rats eating food and he
puts them on a plexiglass plates.
You can observe their mouth movements.
He can distinguish, uh, you know, um,
at the tasty movement of licking your
lips to us, sucrose solution from the,
the disgust expression of gaping and
spitting out things which also human
infants and even show
and typical expressions of Brian's here.
Yeah. So I often make these
expressions, unfortunately, you know,
my students complain about it,
but you do. Uh, yes. But so, uh,
he can distinguish these
as hedonic measured.
So when he calls liking from
actually how much food you eat.
And what he finds is that if you give
them raw dopaminergic drug that stimulates
dopamine, they'll eat more. They
don't show more tasty expressions,
you giving them an opiate
charging drug like heroin. Um,
they will actually not eat,
but they will show more lip smacking.
So we can distinguish the so
called wanting from liking.
And one idea that we've uh,
uh,
we've used his ideas and we've sort of
extended them into the human realm is
that the one thing is about appetitive
motivation is about going out and getting
good stuff. It has an evolutionary
value, uh, and the liking is different.
It's about saying, okay, this was good
and now we should go for more of it.
And so obviously those
things should be correlated,
but it should happen at different points
in a cycle of consuming something.
First you have a positive motivation.
If it gets you to go
out and get good stuff,
then you have the liking and that she
can better feed feedback and informed the
Watson. But the, the,
the new developments in brain imaging
have allowed us to actually just
explicitly in time separate out when you
want something from when you like it.
And we haven't actually looked at at
tastes so much even looked at money cause
we wanted to focus on the wanting
component and money is really great.
It gives you lots of control.
Okay.
Yes. I wondered if you actually
wanted to say something about this.
I mean you developed the tasks that
thousands of researchers have used the
monetary incentive delay task.
Yeah.
So we didn't stay,
we developed this task because we were
frustrated with other aspect of stimuli.
We've found them to be too variable that
people had variable reactions even in
the sugar water. Uh, it's pictures
and so forth. And so we thought,
well money should engage people.
And,
and in fact it does and it shouldn't
elicit affective responses.
And in fact it does. That's a big
advantage. And we've seen this, you know,
not only an undergrads but
also in community samples
and people all around the
world when they are
anticipating a monetary gain.
We see a prominent positive arousal.
We see neural responses when
they're anticipating losing money.
We see positive and negative or, uh, a
prominent negative arousal, not positive.
And we also see other
neural responses to that.
And so it just so happened adventitious
leave that money turned out to be great
brain imaging tool to elicit activity and
these motivational circuits. Um, and so,
uh, we did that work funded
by the NIH and they di,
they funded us because they wanted us
to be able to visualize these circuits
that have also been implicated, not
just in one thing and so forth. Uh,
but also in, uh, uh, psychiatric
disorders. And so, um,
there's sort of two levels of what we do.
One level is what I call the phasic level.
It's sort of like the decisions we
make on an everyday basis. Yeah.
There's what I'd call the tonic level,
which is sort of individual differences
and the responsiveness of these circuits.
And that's, that's the level at which
people are interested in these tasks.
Not just to understand
economic decision making,
but to try to disentangle the
different symptom profiles that people,
psychiatric disorders,
Sab,
and maybe visualize what the
overall responsiveness of
these circuits and try to
understand whether that can help us to
predict how they'll do with a therapy or
a drug regimen or whether they'll improve
such important clinical
health implications of the
work you do and of the tasks
you developed.
I know many people use it in myself,
in my lab trying to parse
apart the nature of, you know,
reward and people suffering from mood
disorders thanks to your task. Well,
I hope it will be useful.
It's a little scary. I mean, you know, uh,
I didn't think it would be so widely
used when we developed it. Uh,
and you never know with neuroimaging,
what's going to be a good probe.
That's part of the reason we have to
do all this localization work is that,
you know, you never know actually how
the brain is responding to things. Uh,
you know, and this is an issue, you know,
just going back to emotion research,
we don't know actually how the brain
is emotionally responding to things.
We don't know if it's doing
so in a dimensional way,
in a categorical way if
it's not doing so at all.
Some people are arguing that
you can't even see value in
the brain, you know, and,
and this seems unlikely to need,
but it could be true.
So on the one hand, there's
all this promise, you know,
maybe we can tease apart psychiatric
symptom profiles, we can predict choice.
On the other hand,
there's still a lot of open questions
about how actually is the brain responding
to things emotional and,
uh,
and how can we visualize that
using the tools that we have.
So lots of unanswered mysteries,
which keeps academics and researchers
in the field busy. Right? Keep us busy.
So you talked a little bit about
how this work has implications for
psychopathology and mental health.
Do you think it has important implications
also for economic decision making?
I do. Um, you know,
I just got back from Nyu where I was
talking about neuro marketing. Hmm.
So there've been all
these kinds of fields.
Neuros dash field's emerging from this
and a lot of promises, you know, uh, by,
not necessarily by scientists but by
people run businesses or the press.
And you know, there's a lot of hype to be
honest. But I do think there is promise.
Uh, and the reason I think
there is promise is that we
can actually at this point
take these signals out of the brain,
these anticipatory that we associate
with positive arousal, negative arousal,
and use them to predict better than
chance whether people will decide to buy
something, whether they will
decide to take a financial risk,
whether they'll decide to take
a gamble for instance. Uh,
and we don't have to know this is without
knowing anything about who you are, uh,
what you saw or your explicit stated
preferences for those items. Um,
so this is pretty exciting. This is
almost like mind reading, if you will.
And we know that these
solutions generalize across
people. So it's not just that,
you know,
I have a really good map of June's brain,
but it's not going to work in my brain.
Um,
so for us this is very exciting because
it gets that not just description and
explanation that also prediction and
perhaps control which are the goals of
science. Um, and, uh,
right now I'd say we're,
we're at about 75% in predicting what
people will buy a and if we ask people
what they like and how much they'll pay a,
I'd say we get a similar predictions.
So,
uh,
but there are other instances where
people have predicted choice even in,
in the,
in the case that somebody has not said
that they explicitly likes something.
So I'm thinking of a study by Greg Burns
on adolescents listening to music and
then trying to predict how well those
songs sold three years later. Uh,
and using nuclease to Cummins
activity to actually predict songs.
Sales when adolescents,
explicit writing ratings of liking
did not predict this on sales.
Those kinds of experiments are like
science fiction and they need to be
replicated obviously. But it's
pretty interesting from, uh,
from the standpoint of applying science.
Well,
and you've also to try to understand
how we anticipate aspect and how that
relates to financial risk taking
too. That's right. Yeah. I mean,
we think that I'm using these methods,
uh,
we can just get another window on
anticipatory effect and the people and use
that to understand not only just minute
to minute or second to second decisions,
but also life financial outcomes. And you
know, a lot of people have looked at, uh,
health outcomes and emotional traits, you
know, and I think that's very important,
actually understudied. Um, but not many
have looked at life financial outcomes.
It's like, you know, how many
assets do you have? How am I,
how many dads do you have? Um, what
is your risk preference profile?
Uh, but in fact, you know, uh,
it could be that these
things are completely
circumstantial. So that is that,
you know,
the things that happened to you in life.
And we all know that those can have a
serious impact on your finances matter
quite a bit.
But it also could be that they're enduring
dispositional effective styles that
influence your financial decisions over
and over and over and that that can have
a cumulative effect on your life.
Financial outcomes.
And we just started in deed
defined that some of our markers,
you both behavioral and neural of an
effect of style are Arlene to life
financial app.
And so we can find for instance that a
performance on a simple game learning
task is linked to assets,
uh, or performance on a
simple loss learning tasks,
which looks the same to a behaviorist is,
is linked to an absence of debts.
This is one of the far out findings
that we have recently that you know,
we're replicating but um,
we can look at these efficacy
profiles sort of bed many levels.
And that's exciting to me too.
So we can not just be comfortable with
asking people on a questionnaire the
psychometrics,
but also trying to link that to brain
structure and brain function. Uh,
and to distinguish it from other types of,
um,
individual differences is like the working
memory or reversal learning or things
like that.
It seems like a really important theme
in your work has really been just linking
data across multiple levels of analysis
to really get at the questions that are
most important.
That's actually how I characterize
our work to students. As I say,
you know what we were added value is or
what we seem to be good at is saying,
here's a really big effect up here.
Here's another big effect down here.
How are those connected?
Are they connected at all?
And it sounds really easy,
but it's actually quite difficult because
you have all these other effects at
this level and at that level
and they're sparse connections.
So only a few of those things are actually
robustly connected. But I find it,
it's really rewarding.
It allows me to talk to and work with
colleagues in other areas and that's how I
want him to fastest.
So when you think then about where the
sort of future of the field is headed,
do you think a big part is linking these
disparate areas or where do you see the
future of emotion headed and Europe?
Wow, I'm biased by you know,
the direction we're going.
So I will be really interested to listen
to your other interviews. You know,
what other people say, be educated.
But of course, you know, for,
for us what I want is this
linking of the levels.
So I want to see how his brain function
connected to effect of self reporting
and how is that connected to choice and
how is that connected to life outcomes.
I want that vertical linkage. Um, and,
and you know, I want it to be empirical.
I want it to have numbers.
Um,
I wanted to have sort of
transfer functions that we
can use to like say, okay,
if this event happened,
if dopamine fired, um,
if they're likely to take this financial
risk. And if they do that enough,
they're likely to put more money
in their bank or not, you know,
and that will have the
following social impact.
So it would be really cool to have
a theory with that kind of power,
that kind of cross level
power. Um, so that's one,
one thing on my wishlist is
to have something like that.
That's a fantastic wishlist.
Items.
Hopefully we'll see what
the funding agencies thing.
So then the last question I had for you
is just what kind of advice would you
give students who are thinking about
embarking in this kind of wild field,
almost science fiction?
Like as you said of emotion.
Um, what, what would you tell them?
It's tricky and I should have thought
about this more before we talked, but you,
because what I usually tell my students
is don't do what I did, uh, which is,
you know, I spent, I literally
spent, you know, nine,
eight or nine years
without any interviews.
So I graduated with a phd,
I went into a Postdoc,
I was on the market, you
know, for eight years. Uh,
nobody was interested
in what I was doing a,
or they probably just
thought it was pulling two
preliminary and then suddenly a
eight interviews and four offers. So, uh,
that was about the time I was
publishing my brain imaging stuff.
So for a while it looked like,
you know,
this guy is doing crazy stuff and
then suddenly everybody's like, oh,
this is feasible. We can do
this. This is interesting.
And so it's very hard to
predict the Zeitgeist guys.
It's sort of like investing.
It's hard to predict the market and I
don't know what the optimal strategy is.
I think, I almost think for a
person like me, if you're like me,
which probably many people are not,
um,
I had to have the intrinsic motivation
to pull me through. Uh, and,
and the conviction that what I was doing
was really the right way to answer the
question,
which is how do emotions were.
I felt like I had to go
to the neural level. Um,
I'm not sure if that's a good strategy.
Now I guess what I would say,
the two things I would say
are get a good strong effect.
The behavioral effect,
not a,
not a neural effect that you can really
tweak in different ways and explain and
explore different levels. Um, that's
one thing that I think is useful.
Another thing is, uh,
get a good method and,
and explore a new method that
you can be an expert in a,
because I think then you're not only an
expert on some sort of field or the fact
that you've investigated, but to be an
expert in a Methodist, quite valuable,
especially in neuro imaging,
the way that things are advancing
every year that are the new things.
And there are new things to explore.
It's not as easy as it sounds because
you want to be an expert in a method that
you think will have some longevity.
But there are so many needs out
there for better methods. Um,
and so I think there's
a lot of opportunity for
students to become experts in
that way.
Thank you so much for speaking
of the three, Ryan. It was great.
Great hearing your thoughts.
This concludes our expert
and emotion interview series.
That's doctor Brian Knutson,
front of Stanford University.